Sure,
this agreement is good for our economy,
it is good for our farmers.
The agricultural commercial efficiency since
two thousand and seventeen has been tripled,
it is good for our milk producers,
for our cheese producers.
These are the objective figures.
Mr. Bardella,
not at all.
I met again recently at.
I was in Toulouse,
I don't know if you see many farmers.
In fact,
to be very honest,
Mr. Bardella,
forgive me,
I am a farmer's daughter.
Ah well,
this is an aggravating circumstance.
Sorry. No, no,
I'm just telling you,
don't lecture me about farmer life,
I think I know it better than you do.
I grew up on a farm,
I have my family and friends around me.
You should not vote what you vote for,
ma'am,
because you have put thousands of farmers in the
streets of I know how diverse agriculture is too.
I know it's not popular to say.
Maybe there are farmers who are doing well,
maybe there are also farmers who are doing very badly," says Bardella,
"on seta and on,
um,
agricultural activity in general.
I went, for example.
I won't even give you a personal example.
I went to Toulouse to campaign last weekend.
I met 1 farmer who said to me,
Mrs. Ayet,
thank you for supporting trade agreements,
with requirement,
of course,
of course.
But thank you for supporting the agreements.
Trade,
because I produce wheat and I need trade agreements to live.
And it wasn't 1 mogul cereal,
huh,
it was 1 medium farm farmer.
This is the reality of the agricultural world.
And when I hear you talking about de,
Mr. Bardella,
I will be the owner of de.
Today,
farmers,
their sources of income,
they are threefold.
First of all,
the national market must be strengthened,
it is obvious.
Welcome,
the common agricultural policy,
the 10 billion that you obviously want to renationalize.
I looked at your program,
I'm not very clear because I saw that you wanted to renationalize it.
I'll explain,
ma'am,
but at the same time you wanted to add national wings to agricultural policy.
You are part of the common agricultural policy.
And then of course,
the third largest source of income is,
uh.
It's uh. The le,
the international trade.
So you want to divide farmers by 2 on this point,
for those who look at us on the issue